we bought actually a big enter button
and once we have it's like a gong so
once we're finding one ability we are
pressing on the enter so it's like a gog
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeword ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel
let's talk about what it's like being a
security researcher a vulnerability
threats researcher
meet sharon brzezinov vulnerability
research team lead at clarity where his
focus areas are critical infrastructure
systems iot devices and malware analysis
under his guidance the vulnerability
research team at clarity has found and
disclosed more than 200 vulnerabilities
most of which have been have been
patched or mitigated by the affected
vendor improving the safety of the ics
domain and critical infrastructure
sectors worldwide
shalon has also participated in
well-known hacking competitions such as
pwn to own and he owns a defcon black
badge for winning the ics ctf contest
okay sean rizzonov welcome to 20 minute
leaders how are you hey thank you very
much i'm great how are you michael i'm
doing great thank you so much for being
here
you're today you run the vulnerability
research team within a clarity and
that sentence is so cool in itself and
while you know i i i come from a little
bit of a cyber background and so i
understand a little bit about what do
you do i i find it so cool and i'm so
excited to get to speak to you in these
20 minutes and share you know this
passion with with the rest of the rest
of my friends and colleagues and because
being a security researcher is not
trivial the process is not trivial the
things that you experience is not your
villain so i'm really excited to get to
know you better you the way you think
but also the life cycle of discovering
these threats what happens before during
and after so siobhan take me back first
a little bit to your childhood how do
you get to become a threat or
vulnerability researcher
yeah okay so that's actually a very
funny story uh when i was when i was a
kid i was really fascinated by uh the
culture of the hackers so i remember
watching i don't know i don't remember
exactly at what age it was but i think
it was around six or seven i uh saw
matrix for the first time and metrics
is the movie about hackers so they're
kind of hacking the metrics which is
kind of a virtual platform that humans
can connect
with machines
through the matrix and i remember
watching this
and i was just fascinated i thought
hackers were so cool they had guns and
they did couple
of cool stunts and i was just amazed so
it took it took me a couple of years to
understand uh that hackers is just it's
not really about
action movies uh rather uh hacking
computers and typing uh fast on the
keyboard
but this is what caught me the
interaction with computers so you can
change the reality inside a computer
this is what fascinated me from a very
early stage
i love it and so how do you act on that
fascination so at an early stage you
realize you're fascinated by these
questions
what what do you do then as a kid how do
you how do you sort of feed your
curiosity with that yeah so it's a good
question so i
i received my first computer at the age
of
eight or nine something like that and i
immediately started to wonder how how
it's working so what is the cpu what is
ram how do you interact with the
computer uh how do you create programs
so very fast i started to create my own
c programs and i started to interact and
create some very simple hello world
style programs
and it was so cool that i was able to
create my own creations using the
computer so i developed a calculator so
i could calculate how much is a two plus
two and i was just fascinated by the
fact that i can create my own product so
this is was my first interaction or my
first introduction with the computer
world and with time i was intrigued and
very i was very interested to understand
how the computer really works so i
invested a lot of time in understanding
how assembly how can i write programs in
assembly and python in page b other
other languages and i started to develop
my own websites my own programs and and
this is how i really got fascinated and
intrigued into the computer world
and so if you fast forward today to the
position of a vulnerability researcher
yeah
dumb it down for me what does that mean
okay so it's a great question um
so where are vulnerability researchers
this means our goal eventually is to
find vulnerabilities and disclosed it uh
to the companies
uh so that they could mitigate
vulnerabilities or remedy them so what
we're doing is we're trying to
understand and think what are the most
common platforms that most uh people uh
or factories are using so i'm coming
from a scada background which means as
you can see uh in the background behind
it this uh this is our lab with lots of
ot and iot equipment this is actually a
critical infrastructure equipment that
is
the brain behind critical infrastructure
such as gas distribution oil
distribution electrical distribution
water facilities so these are plc's
these are the controllers that are
actually the fundamental the brain
behind any critical uh process
and so we try to understand uh what our
customers are using uh what what what
are the most common platforms in those
critical infrastructures and we want to
make sure they they are not vulnerable
so attackers could not uh break into
them so what we're what we're doing is
we're getting these devices we're
setting up
all of them in our lab
and we're trying to poke around and
understand how they're working what the
setup is is
looked like and how can we
find vulnerabilities in them so what
we're doing to do that so we're break
we're trying to kind of break them so
we're uh taking the hardware apart we're
taking the firmware so we're starting to
investigate the firmware and
and analyze what are the attack vectors
that potentially attackers could abuse
in order to infiltrate into these
devices so for example if we're finding
a vulnerability in in the firmware we're
trying to exploit it which means we're
trying to create a poc that will
actually use this vulnerability to the
attacker's benefit
and
with this vulnerability at this hand
they will be able to achieve code
execution so they will be able to take
fully control on this device and from
there they could affect the process so
for example they could change the
temperature
of the water or they can change the
amount of electricity that is allowed to
to be distributed so this is kind of the
thought process and what we're doing in
our lab and in our daily routine clarity
right so i think that brings me to a
really fascinating idea you know most
people that are working in the text in
the tech place or the tech ecosystem you
know they have a yeah they have a task
they know they're going to be developing
it they know that there's going to be a
deadline for the task and there this
feature is going to be deployed and
these are the kpis you don't really have
that you don't have the luxury of saying
you know we need to find the
vulnerability by tomorrow you know
sometimes you don't even know if there
is a vulnerability
we assume there is but
how do you mitigate you know sort of
this the uncertainty behind the life
cycle of finding these vulnerabilities
yeah it's a really good question so
researching is all about the unknown
journey so you get a device you start
poking around but you don't know really
when you will finish this journey so
what we're trying to do is before
defining the kpis for each project we're
trying to understand what are the attack
vectors so once we have the device let's
say we know it has
a network capabilities or it loads files
from certain places we're starting to
understand what are the attack vectors
that attacker could potentially
attack and exploit once we have the
attack vectors we're trying to assess
how much time we will need in order to
reverse engineer the entire uh let's say
the entire uh platform or the entire
attack vector uh functions
so we could have a better understanding
of how the device is working and how
potentially the attacker will attack the
device
and once we have all the
all the information that we need i mean
all the assessment is complete then only
then we're defining kpis of how much
time it will take us to find a
vulnerability if if it exists or not and
so we're scoping this in a very a
specific time frame before moving before
declaring turnover and abilities or
finding common abilities and moving on
to the next project
that makes a lot of sense now
once you find a vulnerability
what how does that work how do you know
you find the vulnerability you mentioned
that then you run the pocs you sort of
put the red team head on and you want to
see okay what can we do with this and
let's say that you found something crazy
you found something insane like being
able to change the amount to run code
that changes the amount of electricity
that is not being distributed
first of all you know beyond you know
the what happens in the professional
world how do how what is the reaction
within your team as the team leader you
know from a leadership perspective
how do you manage this now reaction and
the either excitement stress whatever it
may be
yeah so
uh every time we find a vulnerability
specifically remote code execution uh
we're very happy of course because it
means we're doing our job right
and so we bought actually a big enter
button and once we have it's like a gong
so once we're finding vulnerability we
are pressing on the enter so it's like a
gog
and yeah there is a lot of excitement
and
we're very happy because it means we're
doing our job right and we
we have
brilliant researchers and actually up
until now we found around the 250
vulnerabilities so that's that's quite a
massive number
and
after we're finding vulnerability we're
disclosing this to the appropriate
vendors
so
for example microsoft is a vendor cisco
is a vendor um rockwell schneider
automation is a vendor so there are a
lot of vendors in this ecosystem
and we're exposing the vulnerability to
the vendor which means we're creating a
poc that reproduces the exploitability
of this one ability
and we're writing a short report with
all of our findings
and we're sending this to the vendor
usually big vendors are very happy to
receive
reports from researchers because
it helps them to mitigate these
vulnerabilities so it helps them to make
their products more secure so they're
happy with this and so we're working
with the vendor we're just disclosing
all the information to them and we're
working with them so they us sometimes
ask for our advice how
should they fix the vulnerability
and for a couple of months we're
communicating and working with them to
remedy the vulnerability so once the
vulnerability is remediated usually the
vendor issues fixes or patches to its
customers and only then is when we're
assigning a cve so a cve is like an
identification number for the
vulnerability so all the asset owners
could have the knowledge of what they
need to do if they're vulnerable to this
cv or this vulnerability and usually
what they need to do is to patch and
upgrade it to the new release so
basically this life cycle
of
researching finding vulnerabilities and
disclosing to the vendor really helps
and improves the entire security of the
whole market so
uh vendors are enjoying this benefit of
receiving uh free reports from security
researchers and asset owners are safer
because other attackers could not
exploit these vulnerabilities because
they've been patched
what are some leadership challenges that
you may face or one may face as they're
leading a team of researchers that
obviously
it requires different leadership
management and styles than than managing
a traditional business team or
traditional team of even just engineers
what what what kind of skills or
challenges are you faced with in your
day today
yeah so it's a good question i really
think that the
leading theme of an ability researchers
is quite different from leading a team
of developers because
these are hackers and hackers do not
like to play by the rules which means
you need to be very creative with how
you manage them and how you work with
them on a team so usually it's not like
um
boss and employee it's more like working
together towards achieving a goal and we
must be very creative when we're working
together as a team because finding
vulnerabilities means we need to
bypass some security mitigations so we
need to be very creative when we are
doing that
and so i think that the biggest
challenge is to know how to work with
hackers
in
a team and be creative together
so is it mandatory sort of that you are
one of them
do you think that somebody who's not a
hacker who was not
who isn't able to do the work that
you're doing
could they be a successful team leader
and you know an intimate team leader of
such an organization
so it really depends how
independent the
security researchers are there are some
security researchers that like to play
along so there are lone wolves and they
receive a task find vulnerability in
this device and they will do anything in
their power to achieve this
but when you're doing uh in
vulnerability research at scale so we
have here hundreds of devices and we're
finding vulnerabilities at scale of
hundreds we need to be very efficient
and we need to have lots of manpower and
working together so we could accomplish
this task
that makes a lot of sense what do you
enjoy most
about your work is it the before during
after all together
so i just love the entire process i love
it how
i need to be creative and push my
boundaries every day to find new
vulnerabilities because
vendors are fixing vulnerabilities and
we still need to find vulnerabilities
and bypass
security mitigations and i really
enjoying working with vendors and
actually see how they think how their
developers and generic teams are
thinking about security and i like the
interaction of a security researcher and
the developer engineer the working
together in order to create uh the most
secure devices uh in the world so
right now i can say
uh with some confidence that because of
our uh innovative research i do know
that the scatter world and the ot and i2
devices are much much much more secure
so i really enjoying the fact that we
can shape and make some influence on the
security state of in the entire scatter
market
so obviously when you're approaching a
company or a vendor and you share with
them a vulnerability that you found
especially one that allows one to run
remote code you know there's a big
you know there's
it's a positive idea that you did
because you found it and hopefully
before anybody was able to exploit it
but what is the initial reaction like
what is sort of the reception that you
get from a company and it's like oh
shoot we have a problem on our hand is
it is it shock is it you know anger what
what kind of feedback do you get
yeah so it really depends actually the
size of the company big companies are
are well adapted to this kind of
situation that they're receiving
security reports from
researchers
but smaller companies that it's their
first time uh are very hesitant so i
have a funny story uh we found a
vulnerability in in a plc which is a
controller for a critical infrastructure
and we reported this for the first time
for a very small company a relatively
small company
and they did not understand they could
not understand why we're uh using our
free time uh and sending them
information for free so they thought
we're trying to blackmail them so it was
a very kind of find a funny interaction
uh where we tried to explain them that
we're security researchers and we're
doing this for the community and for the
uh benefit of the entire market and so
it took them unbelievable yeah
i love it
where does the security researcher in
your eyes draw the inspiration
or creativity is it from reading
you know from different reading sources
remaining up to date where is the
inspiration coming from to have this
ingenuity to go and try all these
different things
yeah so
as a security researcher myself i can
say that as a kid i drew my
kind of motivation from movies hacker
movies
uh and today i'm drawing my motivation
from uh great security researchers
around the world and uh from ctfs so
ctfs are kind of uh
hacking competitions where you need to
hack devices and software to achieve
flags and i really enjoy playing ctfs
and hacking competitions myself
and i think it really improves my skills
and
improves and supports my motivation
towards this uh subject
amazing and where in your eyes is the
world going with this so
do you think that you know this model is
is the right way to go that we have you
know a lot of vendors and then we have
these small security teams that are
going to be researching the
vulnerabilities
are we going to have more vulnerability
researchers as though as as you know
time moves forward what how how should
the world adapt to the need that you're
observing today
yeah so it's a good question in in
modern companies uh you don't have just
developers or engineers you have
developers or engineering team and you
also have a security team or red team
that are poking around internally on the
products because developers or engineers
need to be focused on developing fast
their products and sometimes they're
they have some oversights and they're
they're doing security mistakes but
there since they wrote the code that
they don't have uh
the the option to
uh to make these of observations for
security so that's why they need
external entities or internal like rent
internal red teams to do this kind of
job uh and i do think security
researchers like us that are doing this
uh uh across
the entire platforms are very uh a
necessity in this ecosystem because with
the iot world so you have lots of
devices uh your refrigerator is
connected in the internet everyone can
connect to to everyone to everywhere you
have lots of devices and you need
someone to poke around and make sure
vulnerabilities are found and mitigated
before attackers would do that
i love it and and show and i you know
all this is in the context of you know
literally you know we're talking about
companies and one of the things i love
most about the show is talking to people
that are making a positive impact on the
world and you know immediately when you
hear about this about a team that is
finding vulnera that is doing
vulnerability threats research you don't
immediately think of you know the
positive impact but but the truth is
that it's life-saving and and that you
know the work that you're doing you know
you're dealing with the hardware without
with the connected devices that are then
you know the the things that are
powering our hospitals that they're
powering the the world all this
infrastructure and so obviously these
vulnerabilities can be life-threatening
and so by mitigating them you're
actually life-saving and i think that
the context here is important and and a
lot of people need to thank people like
you and and teams like yourselves for
the work that you're doing and clarity
is an amazing company by an amazing
organization and so it's a i'm you
already have a big fan here and i really
want to thank you for your time this was
just inspiring and really really fun and
interesting and uh thank you stay safe
and stay healthy yeah thank you so much
it was such a great time thank you very
much